hello everyone and welcome to a
spectacular game from round two of this
year's stata steel Masters Edition it is
Anish giri versus gukesh and in the
first round Anisha drew his game against
karwana and gokish lost his game to ding
Lyra in the game that we've already
shown but this game it features an
incredible sacrifice that you guys will
be able to find on your own so I'm not
gonna spoil too much uh features a very
exciting opening uh the daragos in
defense so it's not not an IM so but
okay the second best that goes in and uh
well all in all a very exciting game
let's check it out and see what happened
Anish with the white pieces opens with
Pawn to D4 Knight to F6 by Lucas we have
pontacy for E6 and now Knight to F3
going for the antonym so uh we have
Ponte D5 and now Knight the C3 and
Bishop to b b for going for the ragos in
defense with Bishop to G5 and now H6
challenging this bishop and uh yeah
Anish captures now if you're wondering
uh why uh capture the Knight why not
just move the bishop back and keep this
pin it's very hard to do this because
after Bishop to H4 you can play D
captures on C4 and it's very annoying
for white white can't really uh win the
spawn back like you would in a regular
irregular lines for example E3 you can
play B5 and uh this is a very very good
for black for example if Ponte A4 you're
gonna challenge the pawn just C6 and
it's never easy to get rid of this so
that's why after H6 just Bishop captures
an F6 if you play dargozian you might
find this interesting uh sometimes I
played that goes in in Blitz sometimes
people play Bishop H4 and then you can
just capture on on C4 and B at least
equal maybe even better so okay Queen
captures and F6 we have Ponte E3 and now
castles
uh all very standard stuff nothing new
here we have Rook to C1 the characters
on C4 Bishop captures and pawn to C5 now
all main Theory uh we have castles and C
captures on D4 and now uh you will see
uh something like Knight captures and D4
Here pawn captures as possible Queen
captures is possible and of course a
knight uh to E4 is possible uh Knight
the E for attacking the queen is what
Anish goes for he postpones capturing on
D4 uh Queen back to E7 and now Pawn to
A3 now the bush has to move back to A5
as the E7 square has been taken by the
queen uh but okay you want to put your
Bishop on this diagonal uh so so it
works out we have e captures on D4 and
now Rook to d8 putting the rook in front
of the uh the White Queen and usually
you will see here Queen to C2 but the
niche plays Rook the C2 and it is now as
of move 14 that we have a completely new
game it looks like a mouse slip like if
you wanted to take the queen and put on
C2 but this is over the board so obvious
we are not talking about a mouse slip
and also it allows glucose to go for
this very rapid Bishop to D7 now if you
wanted to play something like B4 you
couldn't because Bishop A4 is trouble
for white so of course you have to do
something about that Rook the E2 by a
niche and now Bishop the C6 the bishop
now also on this beautiful diagonal and
once the dark Square Bishop comes to B6
will also occupy this diagonal and
gookish will wield a very deadly Bishop
pair so Queen to C2 now getting off of
that D file with Bishop to B6 and now
Rook F the E1 and here a most
complicated uh position occurs and it's
not easy to spot uh what what to
actually play and it's not easy to
develop your pieces here to give you
what the black should play Black
absolutely must play Bishop to D5
interestingly everything other than
Bishop to D5 loses the game and uh for
example Bishop to D5 uh you have to
counter this very strong Bishop because
there's too much pressure on this E6
pawn and now for example if Bishop
captures and D5 Rook captures Knight the
C3 you will move the Rook to D6 this is
how you tackle all this pressure along
the E file and now even D5 will not be
an issue because black can just continue
development something that the black
will definitely struggle to do otherwise
so if D captures an E6 you will trade a
pair of Rooks play here F characters and
you will have this isolated pawn and
okay we play some like Queen a knight to
D5 attack the queen and the bishop Queen
to C5 trade Queens lets the characters
captures you can even capture on B6 and
one of the positions that is possible
from uh all the way uh move 18 uh that
well black should be able to to hold the
bot it's much easier to play with white
as black has the isolated E Pawn and the
Double B Pawn but even though this isn't
spectacular for for black it's the best
black can do from this position
everything else uh straight out loses
the game and the gookish played King to
h8 and it's not easy to see why this
loses the game but you guys will have
the honors feel free to pause the video
here and try to find the absolute best
move for a niche while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on going uh for for
an all-out sacrificing attack and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Knight E to G5 and there is
no defense against this uh the threat is
of course Queen to H7 Checkmate and the
only way to tackle this is to capture
the Knight you can't play F5 if you play
Pawn to F5 then your E6 Pawn is just
dead I mean Rook captures an E6 and now
your entire position just crumbles
there's there's absolutely nothing you
can do here you can even give up this
Knight and explain at H4 Knight to G6
check I mean nothing works for black
here so of course bookish had the
capture he played age captures on G5 but
now look at this Rook captures an E6 uh
very important in between move and the
reason why it's so important is because
it takes away the E7 and F6 squares from
The Black Queen without the control of
these two squares uh the black queen
cannot keep an eye on the G5 Pawn so F
captures an E6 there really isn't
anything better Rook captures an E6 and
now like I said you cannot keep an eye
on this G5 Pawn if you play Queen to f8
Knight characters on G5 threatens
Checkmate and there's no good way to
defend against this if Queen to G8
you're just gonna play Queen G6 now
threaten this uh and if Bishop to E8
stopping this you can just capture Rook
captures also opens up an attack on the
black queen but it doesn't really matter
if real characters is just gonna deliver
a check and Checkmate that the black
king this way so afterbrook captures an
E6 the Gooker said all right I have to
do something Queen captures an E6 he did
win a lot of material for this but
unfortunately his pieces are too
um uh undeveloped to do anything about
the position Bishop captures an E6 and
now Bishop captures an F3 this is a very
important attacker so of course gookish
eliminates it but Anish does not capture
back even though he could he just plays
Queen to F5 he wants to play Queen to
age three with check and that of course
will be Checkmate once um at the bishop
blocks and queen chapters so Bishop to
E4 the only move that blocks Checkmate
now if play Queen to H3 you can block
with Bishop to H7 so uh Queen captures
an E4 and now Rook captures on D4 this
only makes it easier for Anish um uh to
finish the game but I will even show
what happens with absolute best the
defense if Rook to E8 okay now the queen
can't really go anywhere because the
bishop would hang You're Gonna Play H4
and there's no it's the only winning
move but it's not a difficult one to
find because everything just wins you
have so many squares now where you are
able to go after the black king of
course if captures then Queen will
capture uh if you advance the pawn
doesn't really matter you're just gonna
capture with the queen still you defend
the bishop and you are still threatening
to go for checkmate so at some point
Rook will have to capture Bishop here
let's say Knight to D7 you don't care
you're just gonna play H captors and G5
now G6 is coming uh or or even just a
straight Queen to each for checkmate
Rook counters and E6 you will have to
play this queen captures and now look at
this you have to play something like
Rook to d8 to defend the Knight but I
mean uh you can play pretty much
anything you can advance the pawns black
has no moves here I mean no moves
whatsoever you can't move the Knight
once you move the Knight but okay you
don't want to play G6 to allow Knight to
F6 but uh you're not gonna play G6
unless black moves the Knight and the
black cannot do this you cannot move the
Rook because then the Knight hangs and
what's the bishop gonna do there's
really not much uh for for the bishop to
do I mean it's a very very sad position
so instead after Queen captures an E4
Rook captures and D4 was played but now
the very nice Queen the F3 again
threatening Checkmate and also
preventing Checkmate because now uh
um uh gookers was also planning to
Checkmate the white king So Pawn to G4
now comes Queen to f8 with check King to
H7 Bishop to F5 with check King to H6
and now Bishop the C2 stopping trackmate
and leaving black without a single move
so it was in this position on move 27
that wukish resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here how the
game could progress it's very hard to
say because black does not have a move
you cannot develop anything if you go
back with the Rook uh to maybe try to
develop your pieces you will get to
checkmated just Queen to F4 check and
now it doesn't matter what you play if
you go down the board then just Queen to
F5 check and now if you go up the board
this is Checkmate so you have to go down
the board G3 checking H3 and queen to H5
will be Checkmate and if you don't do
this it doesn't really matter if after
Queen to F or check you go instead of
Queen to H5 you can play G5 then of
course Queen to F6 check into H5 uh king
th5 queen to G6 check English for and
now Queen to H6 will be Checkmate uh so
yeah brilliant stuff but Anish I have no
idea how much of it is preparation
because he really took Lucas out of
preparation with this Rook the C2 move
but I mean you still have to find all of
this and then after Google the the
losing king h8 after Knight to eat the
G5 the position just crumbles uh so
truly spectacular stuff by Anisha there
were some uh very cool games in this
round as well so I will try to cover as
many of them uh but I thought we would
start it off with uh with this one uh so
yeah there you have it hope you guys
enjoyed a tough start for gookish two
losses in row uh but it's still early in
the event uh he might still uh bounce
back so we'll see what happens I would
like to thank randomfile.net Jimbo
Robert key for deutron and ravishing
reptiles YouTube for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
still uh tournament until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day